we cover lots of pop music on this
channel I am after all your hip-hop pop
music Maven Michael Knowles well there
is one artist who is requested probably
more than any other and I've gotten
messages over the last few days say
Michael when this new song drops you got
to review it Michael it's happening in
one day two days you gotta take a look
that song is called Hope by the artist
NF or as I like to call him UNF this
song has just come out so usually we say
10 million views 20 million views this
it just came out so it's got I don't
know I don't even think they've recorded
how many views there are I have not seen
it yet this will be my first look NF
take it away
[Music]
I'm coming
I know you've been waiting
I know you've been praying for my soul
oh
30 years you've been dragging your feet
telling me I'm the reason we're stagnant
30 years you've been claiming you're
right this thing promising Progressive
[Music]
I don't want you to feel like a failure
I know this hurts
but I gave you your chance to deliver
now it's my turn
don't get me wrong
but it's time to give the people
something different
so without further Ado I
like to introduce my mind
hope put a pause there so the song opens
with hope and it seems to be directed to
Hope and the first thing I noticed is
that the second line of the song
references Faith so now you've got two
out of the three theological virtues
faith hope and charity and then charity
and loving kindness is the one where you
don't quite know where it sits in the
song because it opens up on NF sitting
on this little raft in the middle of the
ocean and he says I know you've been
waiting I know you've been praying for
my soul hope hope don't lose faith in me
I know you've been waiting I know you've
been waiting 30 years you've been
dragging your feet telling telling me
I'm the reason we're stagnant
I don't want you to feel like a failure
I know this hurts but I gave you your
chance to deliver now it's my turn so
the question is who is he talking to and
from the very first line it sounds
almost like he's talking to Hope itself
I gave you your chance to deliver hope
as most people believe it is is just a
sense of optimism things are going to
get better now the traditional and
Christian understanding of Hope is that
hope is actually a fact it's a
theological virtue based on a historical
event and so it's it's grounded on
something much more real but a lot of
people today feel that that hope is just
some kind of feeling you know that
people very often feel adrift in a kind
of sea like it's like hope is not
something that is more not something
that's grounded keep going
what's my definition of success
listening to what your heart says
their legs
what's my definition of success create
something no one else
to pay
the paint never waver or change who they
are just to try and gain some
credibility so they can feel accepted by
a stranger it's a person that can take
the fares in their life and turn them
into motivation
Little Bit of Faith can't do if you
don't even believe in you why would you
think or expect anybody else that's
around you too I didn't did things that
I regret I done said things I can't take
back was a lost soul at a crossroad who
had no hope but I changed I put a pause
there so now you see the contrast
between the white guy and the black guy
and the white represents the hope and
the black represents Despair and that
the line about faith
really hits you he says What A Little
Bit of Faith can't do if you don't even
believe in you so faith is the substance
of things hoped for in the evidence of
things unseen we see in the gospel
accounts Christ says if you if you had
the faith of a mustard seed you could
move mountains so faith is a very very
powerful thing but we don't view Faith
it's simply taken on its own isolated
like on a raft in the middle of the
ocean faith has this relationship to
Hope and and so you've got the the black
character of Despair and then you've got
this white character who is just
attacking the the the black pill that
you're getting from Mr despair keep
going
holding on to things I never should have
to catch it
in my life should have walked away from
thickness on my life wishing that was
something different looking for some
validation Tears on My Life
[Music]
changes
my mind is a home I'm trapped in is
moving through the rooms of his mind
your mental breakdown is a negative
thing which I wouldn't have I agree but
on the other hand it was the push I
needed to get help and start the healing
process
of what happens when you choose to not
accept defeating faster demons took me
30 years to realize that if you wanna
get the opportunity to be the greatest
foreign
30 years it's already years and darkness
30 years 30 years of baby 30 years of
sex 30 years of standing 30 years of
change 30 years of patience 30 years of
suffering 30 years of Torment 30 years
30 years have been or 30 years and only
30 years of pushing everyone away
ranks so you see the the black despair
starting to emerge where you you
recognize the now then now the same
person but what's
quite beautiful about this is the
whiteness of Hope
is still in charge I mean this is the
last the last line of the song
you're the one afraid I'm the one in
charge no I'm taking the taking the
reins and who's taking the reins even as
the the despair is emerging this guy
seems to have it in control and how does
he do that well because
we open on the virtues right we open on
two of the three most important virtues
to say nothing of the cardinal virtues
but we open on Faith and Hope and and
even you you see charity there at the
end too when he says Mom I'm not taking
a shot I know I forgive you I'm not
angry I'm not resentful I've actually
got that under control but I don't want
my kid looking out the window saying his
daddy home is he going to be enough I
went through all that and I faced my
demons and I'm in a better spot now and
how is that possible well because of the
virtues because this is a song about
virtue I mean it's the title of the song
and the virtues are things that we
attain when we practice them we practice
these kinds of Virtues and so the more
you practice the virtues the easier they
become to perform the more you engage in
Vice the easier that becomes and the
harder it is to pull away from that and
and he's using this language I I don't
want to be accused of trying to
superimpose my Christian religious view
on on pop music ever I mean part of the
reason that Christianity is usually a
pretty good lens for analyzing the
culture is because this is Western
culture which is animated by
Christianity and so people you even if
they're not consciously religious or
Christian they just use phrases that are
Christian I mean think about all the
idioms that you use in your life that
you might not even be aware of that come
from the Bible you know the blind
leading the blind go the extra mile turn
the other cheek I mean many many other
let there be light these sorts of things
that we just say that obviously have a
Biblical origin in this case though he's
just being so much clearer but he's
talking about demons he's talking about
faith he's talking about Hope and so how
does he overcome it is it merely working
to climb up that mountain he's climbed
up that mountain right so he's undergone
this kind of an effort but could he do
it on his own or is there the one thing
that could be missing in this narrative
is Supernatural Grace could he have
overcome these these demons on his own
or is there something else there you
know faith is the substance of things
hoped for and the evidence of things
unseen so what is that thing well
obviously this is an intro to a much
longer story a much longer narrative
it's clearly setting up the album so
then the question is what comes next
where does this go what I really like
about this song is it doesn't tie a
little bow around to the end and have a
nice conclusion here it's it's really
opening up a much broader story which
which he is saying is the broader story
of his life 30 years 30 years and now
he's the one taking the reins where is
that going to go
I enjoyed it I'm Michael Knowles we'll
see you next time foreign
[Music]